やられたぜ
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
ありがとうございます
一昨日くらいに片頭痛で病み上がりで治りましたって言ってたんですけど
よーく考えたら一日で治るわけありませんでした
頭痛は大丈夫なんですけど
なんだろ　喉の痛みと咳が
止まらないっす
あれ発音がまたおかしいって言われる
咳　咳　咳　咳
咳が止まらない
咳　咳　咳が止まらないです
咳が止まらないと鼻水がやっぱひどいんすよ
風邪じゃなくても年中鼻水が出るタイプの人間なので
ホント鼻水どうにかしないと
動画も撮れないぞってくらい鼻水が出るので
今回はこちら
鼻洗浄
１回で３００
待て、値段がやばいんだよ
この値段ですよ
1回300ml本格タイプ
耳鼻科医が考えた本格鼻洗浄機
いやーガチっぽいでしょう
結構昔に僕やったんですよねたしか
ハナノアっていうね
どこにでも売ってるような
あの安っぽいやつでやってるんですけども
もう全然鼻になんか液を入れて口から出すってのをやったんですけど
全然ダメ
本格的な鼻洗浄マシーンだったらきっと鼻が良くなるんじゃないかなっていうわけで
使っていきましょう
分かる？この
体は悪くないんすよ
別にだるいとかあんまり無いんですけど
純粋に咳が止まらないパターン
全然大丈夫なんですけど
咳と鼻水がひどいから
動画を撮る時にはちょっとしんどいかなって感じです
こっちは洗浄剤っすね
こんな感じです
電池とか必要ないのかな？
えっとまずまずまずですね
まず水洗い
お湯を準備しないといけないのか
いんじゃない？いんじゃない？
ここがちゃんと反応してくれます
これ今完璧です
本当に鼻づまりがひどいんすよ
てかあのなんかあれですよ
お前ら
今も悪かったね
俺が滑舌悪いと思っているだろ？
それは俺のせいじゃない
全てこの鼻づまりのせいなので
皆さん僕の鼻が良くなること祈ってください
お願いします！
一袋入れなきゃ
お薬チックなやつをひとくつえ
お薬チックなやつを一袋
お薬チックなやつを一袋入れます
うわやべぇこれガチっぽいなこれ
よしよし　OK OK
よく溶かす
よく溶かすと？
ボールペンしか無いや
しっかりと溶かしましょうこうやって
OKです　いいのではないでしょうか
で、これを
ポンプ本体をしっかり
ポンプ本体を
ほら　ね？喋ってるだけでこのざま
よしOKOK
もうこれ来る来る
皆さんもう来ますよ
できました　で、ノズルを
ノズルを軽く鼻に
ノズルを軽く鼻に当て
前かがみになり
”え～”と発声しながら左右交互に３回ずつポンプを押し
洗浄液が無くなるまで鼻に入れます
ひとまず３回ずつこれを押せばいいんですね
いきましょう
*くしゃみ*
も～色々とやばいんだけど
くしゃみと鼻水と咳が止まらん
鼻に入れて
”え～”と言いながら３回押すのを交互にするらしいです
え～～～～～あｄぬうぇいｙｆ～～～＾こんうがっ
ちょっと違うでしょこれ
”え～”って言いながら押してくださいって書いてある
で、３回ポンプを押す
안녕하세요
普通に汚いでしょ
悔しい
え～～～～～あ　wwwwwwwwwwwwwww 안녕하세요
*くしゃみ*
もう一歩なんですけどね
*え～とあ～の繰り返し*안녕하세요
全然止まらんやんけ
え～～～～～～～
ホントにｗ
というわけで皆さん夏風邪に気をつけましょう
じゃあな